初めに皆さんに一つ深めの質問をします
皆さんにとって一番大切なものは何ですか
これは想像なのですが家族という言葉が
浮かんだ人も多いのではないでしょうか
こちらは統計数理研究所から奪ったデータ
なのですか
このように1973年から2013年に
かけてみても一番大切なものとして家族を
挙げる人が最も多くなっています
家族というと何か特別な存在に思いますよ
ねー
しかし皆さん
なぜ家族は大切なのでしょう
通して家族が一番大切だと言うのでしょう
か
この質問は誰にするかによっても答えが
違うかもしれません
私は今16歳高校一年生です
海外ではティーンとも呼ばれ年代ですが
学校や塾深津アルバイト様々な場所で居
場所をつくり式です
将来の事を真剣に考えたり人間関係を作っ
ていくうちに自然と自立するものです
そんな高校生にとって家族が一番大切かと
聞かれると少し悩んでしまうかもしれませ
ん
こちらは東京ガスと私生活研究所が行った
調査何ですか
高校生の約20%ほどしか
家族との時間を過ごしたいと回答しません
でした
さらに調子が学生を対象にして行なった
アンケートでは関心があることは何ですか
という質問に対して
家族家庭のことと回答したのは全体の約
13%で1位の成績事件のことをや音楽の
ことの60%とは大きな朝でした
注意としては16位です
ちょうど高校1年生の私が考えても高校生
になると
家庭以外のことで精一杯になってしまって
距離ができてしまうように感じます
そして自由にしてほしいという想いも持つ
と思います
同じく調子が行った調査では
家ニール大人に何をしてほしいですかと
いう質問に対して
もっとも多かった回答がしつこくいろいろ
聞かないでほしいと大人の考え方を
押し付けないで欲しいというものでした
ここから見えるのは犯行キーが来る理由に
はティーンが成長するにつれて大人のせい
で自分の思い通りにいかないことがあると
ストレスを感じてしまうということが挙げ
られます
私自身を親に自分のやろうとしていること
を批判されたり
もっとこうしなさいと言われたりするうち
に
いやイライラしてしまい
その怒りをあらわにして親とケンカになっ
てしまうこともあります
しかし私にはそれが変わるきっかけがあり
ました
今日はそのきっかけと底から思う家族に
ついて話していきたいとおもいます
私が家族について考えるようになった
きっかけはこの中でした
内路コロナはたくさんの人に様々な影響を
及ぼしましたが私にとっては母との時間が
圧倒的に増えたということでした
私の土は単身赴任で家にいない
私は一人っ子で兄弟もいない
そしてこの中の2020年春は完全に外出
自粛
つまり私は24時間母と二人きりだったの
です
初めは上手く行っていたと思うのですか
だんだん家にいる時間が長くなるにつれて
母に言われる小さなことに向かってきたり
家事を頼まれると eu もなく嫌がっ
たり家の中の空気が本当に最悪になって
しまうことがありました
もっと大変だったのはこの7自粛明けて
徐々に家から出るようになった時でした
私は学校も部活も再開して友達にも会える
ようになって行った自由だと思ったのです
が母は違いました
私がこのように感染してしまうことを
とても不安に思って部活はでるなーとか
出かけようとすると常識がないとまで言わ
れました
コロナのことになるとハートは考え方が
違いすぎていつも喧嘩になっていました
私の事情も分からないのになんで踏み込ん
でくるのと母が本当に嫌になってしまう
ことがありました
この中で家族て過ごす時間は増えたはずな
のに関係が良くなったとはこの時はとても
いやませんでした
しかしいま思うとこの時の自分に言いたい
ことがあります
それは家族だからといってそれだけで特別
な関係になれるというわけではないという
ことです
これは調度品は傭兵の小説で2013年の
ヒットドラマにもなった家族ゲームにも
ある考え方ですか
本音を話さなければ家族にはなれないと私
は思います
私と母がこの中で関係が悪くなってしまっ
たのはお互いの本音が見えていなかったか
なと思います
uc バークレーの心理学者搬送しは人と
の関係を深めるにはどれだけ本紙に近い
ことを話せるかがカギだと話します
大げさに物事を言ったり本と思っている
ことを言わなかったりするうちに
緩急は自然と薄くなってしまいます
私は自分でも気づかないうちにコロナ
ne-yo れストレスをたくさん抱えて
いました
外出したいという頑なな思いの裏には他の
子が外に出かけているのになんで私だけ
という嫉妬と焦りも隠れていた気がします
頃の怖がる母に対して怒りを覚えてしまう
のは様々なことを変えてしまった
パンデミック時代に対しての怒りも潜んで
いた気がします
しかし私はそんな本音を母に話してはい
ませんでした
この中を2年と鈴木
毎日のようにストレスになることが起こる
に擦れて私は待つますイライラしていまし
た
母や友達の前では明るく振る舞うことも
ありましたが何かのきっかけで怒りが爆発
したり
な水面が触れたりと感情の村が
エスカレートしていました
その時私は気づいたら母日本でお話してい
ました
本音を話すというと何か自分の中に溜めて
あったものを吐き出すというような
イメージを持つかもしれませんが私にとっ
ては自分でも気付いていなかったことを
言葉に出しながら築いていくというような
感覚でした
そうすると母は話をじっくり聞いてくれ
ました
そして母の方にも変化がありました
今まであまり話してくれていなかった父が
この中で海外にいることに対しての不安を
時に感情を表に出しながら話してくれまし
た
今まで母の悩みのことなんて考えたことも
ありませんでしたか
話してくれたことをきっかけに母のことを
真剣に考えるようになりました
東洋大学社会学部の西の京地は家族の間で
は特に家族なんだから気持ちなんて話さ
なくてもわかる
わざわざ気持ちを言うなんててれると思っ
てしまいがちです
しかしたとえ血はつながっていても家族は
他人です
自分の気持ちをわかって欲しい重い相手の
ことを思いやる気持ちは家族の中でも保た
なければなりません
私が初めに聞いた質問に戻ります
なぜ家族は大切なのでしょう
私は本音を話せる場所だからだと思います
家族にはどんな本音を話しても決して
キラーれず愛してもらえる場所
そしてお互いの生活に干渉でき
真剣にお互いのことを考え会える場所
そんな場所だから
家族は大切なのです
ティーンにとっては特に大切な場所です
自立したいという思いが強いのに一番
ストレスを感じているのです
アメリカ心理学会を行った最新研究では
ティーンと大人がそれぞれ自分のストレス
度を10点満点のスコアで表したとき
ティーンの値が大人もの平均で1.7
上回ったと回答しました
そしてそのキーの42%がそのストレスに
対してどう対処したら良いか分からないと
話しています
私はこれを解決する大きな鍵が家族だと
思います
私は母との関係が良くなったことで自分の
ストレスがコントロールできるようになっ
たと確実に言えます
だから私はこれからも自分の本で
ありのままに思ったことを家族に話して
いきたいとおもいます
今では家族のことを真剣に考えることを
恥ずかしいとは思いません
だからこそこうしてみなさんの前でお話し
しようと思いました
皆さんも一度自分にとっての家族について
考えてみてはいかがですか
ご静聴ありがとうございます